alors voilà ce que l'on va faire un mémo
avec de la décoration de noël donc pour
faire votre mémo prenez d'abord une
planche de bois et recouvrez la de
peinture disposer ensuite vos
décorations selon vos envies
un atelier de noël pour petits et grands
sous la direction de florence coquard
ces ateliers sont destinés pour les
parents et les enfants
d'accord donc on accepte les enfants
accompagnés d'un parent donc accessible
à tous alors on prend pas des tout
petits tout petit apport pour tous ce
qu'est mémo au niveau de la décoration
ce qui leur permet aussi de pouvoir
coller peindre est vraiment
personnalisée selon leurs goûts
une recette qui a déjà fait des adeptes
c'est la deuxième fois que sabine
participent aux ateliers de l'espace
yves montand et une quinzaine de jours
on a fait le calendrier de l'avent et ma
fille a adoré et il ya aujourd'hui
décide j'ai décidé de participer à cet
atelier pour lui faire le mémo on est
vraiment là dedans on pense pas autre
chose et ça déstresse en même temps j'ai
reposant calme puis on apprend des
nouvelles techniques
voilà ça ça fait travailler un petit peu
aussi l'imaginaire un atelier programmé
samedi 17 décembre comptait 1 euro 50
l'inscription florence vous apprendra
même à créer la botte du père noël seule
limite la créativité